wir kommen jetzt zu einem kriminalfall
der uns auch hier in der redaktion den
ganzen tag beschäftigt so heftig ist er
so brutal es geht um den mord an der an
der 19 jahre alten prostituierten andrea
k sie hat mit einer betonplatte an den
füßen es sie in der weser versenkt
worden und unsere reporter haben sich
auf die spuren ihres kurzen lebens
begeben
ein kleines mädchen mit dunklen locken
und brille sitzt auf einem campingstuhl
es hat die finger zum siegeszeichen
geformt fiebert bei der wm 2010 mit der
deutschen nationalmannschaft mit
das mädchen ist andrea k zehn jahre
später treibt ihre leiche in einem
seitenkanal der weser ihre hände waren
auf dem rücken gefesselt mit einem
knoten wie ihn die sadomaso szene
benutzt an ihren füßen eine schwere
gehwegplatte so wurde sie in die weser
geworfen und das noch lebendig andrea
damals gerade 19 jahre alt qualvoll
ertrunken ermordet ende april wurde ihre
leiche bei nienburg in niedersachsen aus
dem kalten fluss gezogen
wer ist das mädchen das so grausam
ermordet wurde
andreas mutter verließ die familie früh
der vater war mit der erziehung der vier
kinder überfordert andrea wuchs mit zwei
älteren und einem jüngeren bruder bei
helmstedt auf
bild traf den bruder der ermordeten
andrea er versteht nicht wie jemand so
etwas seiner schwester antun konnte
nach bild-informationen ist dieser
mutmaßliche zuhälter aus der bdsm szene
nun in haft stefan k er soll andrea in
die weser geworfen haben um sie ohne
jede spur loszuwerden
offenbar weil sie aussteigen wollte als
prostituierte
wie bild erfuhr spielt aber noch eine
weitere figur aus dem rotlichtmilieu
eine rolle
diego dts ein typ der damit prahlte wie
viel geld er habe vielleicht war es die
aussicht auf ein leben ohne geldsorgen
dass andrea in seine arme trieb andreas
bruder erinnert sich noch wie seine
schwester über diego de sprach
er soll nach polizei erkenntnissen einer
der täter sein die andrea ermordeten
offenbar wollte er sie an stephan käfer
kaufen
beide männer wurden ende der woche
zusammen mit stefans lebensgefährtin und
einem weiteren komplizen verhaftet
die staatsanwaltschaft wirft ihnen
gemeinschaftlichen mord vor
mittlerweile hat andreas bruder ein
spendenkonto für die beerdigung
eingerichtet um seiner schwester die
letzte ehre zu erweisen die sie verdient
hat